Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today I am going to try to tell you the glorious
tale of AI-based human face generation and
showcase an absolutely unbelievable new paper
in this area.
Early in this series, we covered a stunning
paper that showcased a system that could not
only classify an image, but write a proper
sentence on what is going on, and could cover
even highly non-trivial cases.
You may be surprised, but this thing is not
recent at all.
This is 4 year old news!
Insanity.
Later, researchers turned this whole problem
around, and performed something that was previously
thought to be impossible.
They started using these networks to generate
photorealistic images from a written text
description.
We could create new bird species by specifying
that it should have orange legs and a short
yellow bill.
Then, researchers at NVIDIA recognized and
addressed two shortcomings: one was that the
images were not that detailed, and two, even
though we could input text, we couldn’t
exert too much artistic control over the results.
In came StyleGAN to the rescue, which was
then able to perform both of these difficult
tasks really well.
Furthermore, there are some features that
are highly localized as we exert control over
these images, you can see how this part of
the teeth and eyes were pinned to a particular
location and the algorithm just refuses to
let it go, sometimes to the detriment of its
surroundings.
A followup work titled StyleGAN2 addresses
all of these problems in one go.
So, StyleGAN2 was able to perform near-perfect
synthesis of human faces, and remember, none
of these people that you see here really exist.
Quite remarkable.
So, how can we improve this magnificent technique?
Well, this new work can do so many things,
I don’t even know where to start.
First, and most important, we now have much
much more intuitive artistic control over
the output images.
We can add or remove a beard, make the subject
younger or older, change their hairstyle,
make their hairline recede, put a smile on
their face, or even make their nose pointier.
Absolute witchcraft.
So why can we do all this with this new method?
The key idea is that it is not using a Generative
Adversarial Network, a GAN, in short.
A GAN means two competing neural networks,
where one is trained to generate new images,
and the other one is used to tell whether
the generated images are real or fake.
GANs dominated this field for a long while
because of their powerful generation capabilities,
but, on the other hand, they are quite difficult
to train and we have only limited control
over its output.
Among other changes, this work disassembles
this generator network into F and G, and the
discriminator network into E and D, or in
other words, adds an encoder and decoder network
here.
Why?
The key idea is that the encoder compresses
the image data down into a representation
that we can edit more easily.
This is the land of beards and smiles, or
in other words, all of these intuitive features
that we can edit exist here, and when we are
done, we can decompress the output with the
decoder network and produce these beautiful
images.
This is already incredible, but what else
can we do with this new architecture?
A lot more.
For instance, two, if we add a source and
destination subjects, their coarse, middle,
or fine styles can also be mixed.
What does that mean exactly?
The coarse part means that high-level attributes,
like pose, hairstyle and face shape will resemble
the source subject, in other words, the child
will remain a child and inherit some of the
properties of the destination subjects.
However, as we transition to the “fine from
source” part, the effect of the destination
subject will be stronger, and the source will
only be used to change the color scheme and
microstructure of this image.
Interestingly, it also changes the background
of the subject.
Three, it can also perform image interpolation.
This means that we have these four images
as starting points, and it can compute intermediate
images between them.
You see here that as we slowly become Bill
Gates, somewhere along the way, glasses appear.
Now note that interpolating between images
is not difficult in the slightest and has
been possible for a long-long time — all
we need to do is just compute average results
between these images.
So what makes a good interpolation process?
Well, we are talking about good interpolation,
when each of the intermediate images make
sense and can stand on their own.
I think this technique does amazingly well
at that.
I’ll stop the process at different places,
you can see for yourself and let me know in
the comments if you agree or not.
I also kindly thank the authors for creating
more footage just for us to showcase in this
series.
That is a huge honor, thank you so much!
And note that StyleGAN2 appeared around December
of 2019, and now, this paper by the name “Adversarial
Latent Autoencoders” appeared only four
months later.
Four months later.
My goodness!
This is so much progress in so little time
it truly makes my head spin.
What a time
to
be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!